Eh bien, bonjour !
Je suis assis sur ce canapé
aux côtés de mes 3 grands collègues :
Freddy Gladieux ~
KezahProd(uction)
et JOYCA de la "Joycance", ici présents
Je suis très heureux les gars que vous soyez là
J'ai préparé ce concept depuis un bon moment
Nous allons nous affronter
pendant les 3 prochains jours
2 équipes : Joyca et moi
Kezah et Freddy
(Freddy : J'crois que c'est ça !)
Dans chaque équipe se trouve un potentiel chanteur
et un mec qui sait manier un logiciel de production musicale.
Pendant 3 jours, on va chacun être dans notre studio
et on va devoir faire un hit de l'été
Freddy : ... Non ?!
Squeezie : Ah t'étais pas au courant ?!
[Kezah rigole]
Freddy : Si je l'étais ! Je l'étais !
Squeezie : Aaah ! Non mais attends mec... !
[en même temps] Freddy : Il y a cru ou pas ?
Squeezie : Non mais lui il est fort en comédie quoi !
Un hit de l'été, c'est quoi ?
C'est un son... cool à entendre
qui est un peu dansant, etc.
Vous pouvez ajouter ce que vous voulez, vous avez le choix
vous pouvez faire le genre musical que vous voulez
Et vous avez 3 jours pour ça
A l'issue de ces 3 jours,
vous aurez donc fait le beat,
vous aurez donc trouvé les paroles,
vous aurez donc posé sur le beat...
Bref, vous aurez fini votre son et on l'enverra au mix
Nous, pareil de notre côté
Pendant tout ce temps, on a aucune idée de ce que vous allez faire
et vous avez aucune idée de ce qu'on va faire
On se retrouvera une fois que le son aura été mixé
Donc le son sera dans son état final,
prêt à être diffusé,
et on découvrira, chacun, le hit de l'été de l'autre équipe
Ok ?
Freddy : Pour l'instant, ça me va !
Joyca : C'est bien expliqué aussi
Mais... C'est quand même une battle...
Il y a quand même un gagnant dans l'histoire
Donc nous allons envoyer nos sons à un maître de la chanson française,
un artiste qui a vendu énormément d'albums...
Freddy : Aznavour !
[en même temps] Squeezie : ...qui fait énormément de streams
Joyca : J'ai pensé à la même chose !
Freddy : Ah... J'me suis... Je suis mal l'actu
Cet artiste nous enverra une petite vidéo de lui
qui découvre nos sons, et qui donne son avis
et qui élit, selon lui, le gagnant !
Freddy : Ok
Squeezie : ça ne s'arrête pas là !
Parce qu'on veut aussi l'avis des gens !
Donc ce qu'on va faire après ça
C'est qu'on chacun va cliper notre son,
et ça sortira
48h après cette vidéo-là,
que vous êtes en train de regarder
Donc les 2 clips seront en ligne sur ma chaîne,
et c'est tout simplement le clip qui aura le plus de "J'aime" qui gagnera la battle
Donc vous découvrirez, en même temps que nous,
le clip de Freddy et Kezah
et vous découvrirez, en même temps qu'eux,
le clip de Joyca et moi !
Est-ce que tout est clair et lucide ?
Freddy : Il m'le semble ?
Squeezie : Les amis !
C'est parti pour "Qui fera le meilleur hit de l'été ?"
On dirait vraiment le nom d'une émission de télé pas très ouf...
et pourtant on est sur YouTube !
Et ça va être ouf !
Kezah : Ah je pense !
Squeezie [en clapant des mains] : Les amis ! C'est parti !
A tout de suite !
[Freddy veut se lever. Moment de blanc.
Squeezie rigole, les 2 autres le suivent]
[musique]
Kezah : Après cette explication de Lucas, on se retrouve là, en bas !
Bah vous savez pas mais on est en bas du bâtiment,
dans le studio,
qui est également le studio
je sais pas si on peut le dire mais
de McFly et Carlito
Freddy : Ok, tu l'as dit !
Kezah : Le Summer Hit... Comment on le fait ?
Faut que ça soit hyper joyeux dans les accords, dans les instruments, j'pense
Freddy : P*tain je voulais être triste,
moi j'suis vraiment dans la période comme hier...
[en même temps] Kezah : C'est vrai que pour l'été, c'est bien...
Freddy : Tout le monde fait ça non ?
Tout le monde reste enfermé chez soi et pleure
Squeezie : Mec ! Pour moi, un hit de l'été
c'est... Latino en ce moment !
[Squeezie fait du beatbox à la "latino". Joyca le suit en ajoutant sa petite touche personnelle]
Squeezie : Tu connais !
C'est quoi ton avis ?
C'est toi le boss mec ! Moi j'suis une m*rde à coté de toi...
Joyca : Mon avis, pour un bon hit de l'été, si vous êtes prêt
à charbonner
comme jaja
... ou comme Djadja !
Squeezie [en écho] : comme Djadja !
[les 2 rigolent comme des idiots]
Joyca : La... règle n°1 : laisser la place à la voix !
Il faut que dans notre instru, on ait des p'tites notes un p'tit peu caché,
un p'tit peu étouffé comme ça,
[parle dans ses mains pour imiter une voix étouffé]
pour que la voix elle puisse ressortir de ouf
et qu'on ait PEU d'éléments
pour que, justement, la voix prenne toute l'ampleur
Squeezie : On peut chanter posé, mais il faut qu'il y ait de l'autotune,
j'pense que dans le hit de l'été, y'a de l'autotune mec !
Joyca : Ouais, bien sûr !
[en même temps] Squeezie : Vraiment, c'est évident !
Eh mec ! J'ai mis mes lunettes, j'me sens plus là !
Eh mec, j'suis Avicii ! J'tai dit que j'étais Avicii ?
Aaah... C'est triste, on parle de lui... Il est décédé le pauvre...
Joyca : Bah non mais, continuons de n*quer le mood de cette vidéo hein ?
Squeezie : Parlons d'autres artistes morts peut-être ?
Joyca : Dick Rivers est mort aujourd'hui, là... à 73 ans.
Abonnez vous, activez la cloche ! Aïe aïe aïe !
Kezah : Bon on part sur quoi ?
Freddy : Bah, j'sais pas... le soleil quoi...
Bah ça veut dire que t'écoutes un truc, tu bronzes des oreilles
Kezah : "Tu bronzes des oreilles"... pal mal !
Faut que ça respire le... le mono'i, tu vois ?
Cancún, tu vois ? Cap-d'Ail pour ceux qui ont moins de budget mais...
Freddy : Ouais... ce qui ont moins de budget : Evry ! C'est au Sud de Paris
Kezah : C'est pas mal !
Freddy : Ouais
Dans le jargon, j'pense qu'on va employer des "pluck"
C'est des p'tis synthé très ODM, dans le style
Freddy : Décidément y'a que des mots qu'on connaît pas
Kezah : Un peu euh... Avicii !
Freddy : Ok !
Kezah : Avec un p'tit instrument, genre...  sur le refrain,
un truc un peu "gimmick", tu vois ?
Un truc qui reste bien en tête
En fait, le hit de l'été c'est ça :
c'est un truc qui reste en tête !
Freddy : Mais que l'été !
Kezah : Ouais : en septembre t'as la flemme
Freddy : Ok, ouais... C'est que pour l'été
Squeezie : T'as pas des prods ? Des trucs à faire écouter, en stock, comme ça peut-être on peut...
Joyca : Mec, j'en ai quelques unes :
J'ai quelques prods sur lesquelles j'ai avancé, un peu dans des latino comme ça
Là tu me dis totalement ce que tu en penses : si c'est de la m*rde, tu me dis "C'est de la m*rde !"
Squeezie : Vas-y !
[~Musique à la latino~]
Joyca : On garde pour après
Mais déjà, là le petit synthé ?
Squeezie : Très bien !
Joyca : Y'a... y'a un p'tit délire !
Squeezie : Ouais mais si tu mets derrière le
[imite un rythme latino]
Joyca : Bah il est là !
[suite de la musique latino, avec de la percussion]
Squeezie : Bah voilà !
[la musique continue]
Joyca : Derrière !
[quelques notes, très rythmiques, sont ajoutées]
Squeezie : Bien ça !
Joyca : ça monte, ça va monter !
Squeezie : La basse ?
[la musique enchaîne, avec des notes basses en plus]
Joyca : Si... si y'a le mouvement de tête, c'est... C'est que c'est pas mal !
Squeezie : Mec, c'est vraiment bien ! C'est vraiment bien ! Là y'a un vrai potentiel fou !
Joyca : Celle que je vais te faire écouter là, maintenant, c'est plus classique
Squeezie : Ouais
Joyca : Vraiment Latino, Reggaeton, euh...
Classique pur euh... pur et simple
[Joyca démarre sa deuxième prod]
[avec un effet d'écho comme un "souvenir",  un "rêve"]
Là tu me dis totalement ce que tu en penses : si c'est de la m*rde, tu me dis "C'est de la m*rde !"
Squeezie : EUH... Ok !
Donc, je pense, prends la première prod que t'as fait,
elle va nous servir de base
Joyca : D'accord
Squeezie : Et on va modifier la structure etc
pour atteindre autre chose
Kezah : Bah ouais ! Du coup, pluck ! Synthé pluck, un peu, tu sais, en contre-temps
Freddy : Mec, j'ai envie de te dire que tu m'apprends ce qu'est le pluck !
Je te laisse euh...
Kezah : Bah écoute, je pense qu'on va en trouver un !
[musique]
Kezah : Bah c'est pas du tout ça un pluck...
[Autre musique]
Freddy : C'est pas ça non plus
Kezah : C'est pas ça non plus
Freddy : Est-ce que c'est... ça ? [tape sur la table] non !
Joyca : Tu veux qu'on commence par la mélo ?
Squeezie : Ouais, j'pense, ouais
[en même temps] Joyca :  Le p'tit lead de mélo où on va se trouver un p'tit délire ?
Squeezie : J'pense : moi je trouve ça pas mal
Donc là, on va trouver l'instrument qu'on utilise déjà
Joyca : Moi j'aime bien utilisé des petites samples,
comme par exemple t'as ça :
[bruit qui ressemble à celui d'un train]
Tu vois ? Tu vas prendre ça, tu le samples
Il était très agressif
Squeezie [se moque] : C'est... c'est un train qui vient de passer, vraiment ?
Joyca [se justifie] : Non mais, non mais t'en a plein tu vois, et...
[une note]
Joyca : Tu vois ? Juste un petit truc comme ça !
Squeezie [en même temps] : Ah ouais ! ouais ! ouais !
Joyca : Et on peut la garder soit longue comme ça : donc faire juste 3 notes
Taoung ! Taoung Taoung !
[il imite les notes qui sortent du PC]
Squeezie : Ah, c'est pas mal !
Joyca [chantant] : Ma belli, ma bella !
Squeezie [chantant aussi] : La la la !
Joyca [chantant toujours] : Je suis amassé dans ma favela ! ~
Squeezie [qui suit] : La la la...
[grézillement]
[biiiiiip]
Squeezie : Rajoute derrière le
[fait du beatbox avec un rythme latino]
pour voir ce que ça donne
[musique, avec en percussion le rythme que Squeezie vient de faire]
Squeezie : Mec, j'aime bien hein
Joyca : Ouais ?
Squeezie : On en pense quoi derrière la caméra ?
Edmond Trépied : Top !
Céleste Miseaupoint : Cool !
Joyca : P*tain, c'est cool !
Kezah : Freddy ?
Freddy : Ouais ?
Kezah : Bon aujourd'hui on fait un 102...
Freddy : Ok
Freddy : Aah ! Mais j'suis utile quand même ?
Kezah : ...... Mouais !
Freddy : Ouais...
Kezah : Bah déjà, là, le 1er truc que tu peux faire là, c'est genre appuyer sur Rec, tu vois ?
Freddy : Et ça c'est les gens vraiment utiles qui font ça...
Kezah : Bah en vrai, t'as une responsabilité de ouf quand même !
Freddy : Ouais mais c'est ce que j'dis, c'est ça !
Kezah : Bah en vrai, si t'appuies pas cette touche, bah le son il existe pas
Freddy : Ok !
Kezah : Bon aller, vas-y : on enregistre le pluck !
[Freddy appuie sur la touche pour enregistrer]
[son de métronome]
[Kezah joue quelques accords pluck]
Kezah : ... Le pluck, normalement, c'est bon
Freddy : Je pense... que c'est un hit... déjà !
Franchement, on arrête là !
Kezah : Mais tu peux pas t'arrêter comme ça !
Freddy : Ouais... c'est vrai...
Il faut quand même aller plus loin ... ?
Kezah : Ouais, il faut aller plus loin
Freddy : Tu veux dire que je suis trop optimiste ?
Kezah : Non, t'es surtout très pressé !
[Freddy rigole]
Squeezie : Ok ! Donc on a 3 options :
On a celle-là qu'on vient de créer ensemble
Joyca : Ouais voilà
Squeezie : Et on a tes 2 autres prods que t'avais créé avant
Joyca : Ouais
Joyca : ça, c'était la 1ère !
[musique]
Joyca : L'autre... BIEN plus reggaetone
[musique reggaetone]
[avec un effet d'écho comme un "souvenir",  un "rêve"]
Si c'est de la m*rde, tu me dis "C'est de la m*rde !"
Et du coup on a ça sur la fin
Bon c'est... vraiment y'a 3 pistes hein
Squeezie: Ouais !
Pardon il s'est passé quoi là ?
La faiblesse !
En vrai, les deux premières étaient pas mal hein
Je suis vraiment d'accord
Criez très fort tous ceux qui sont d'accord
Cadreur 1: Ouais!
Cadreur 2: Ouaiiiiis
Joyca : Ouais tu vois, je me disais
Mais tu vois, la première qui est plus "raggaeton" je suis en train de me tâter
Joyca : Faut que je sois dans l'ambiance
Permets moi de me lever
Squeezie : Et là c'est bien là là
[Squeezie chantonne une potentielle mélodie]
[Joyca le rejoint]
Squeezie : Là y'a un truc à faire
Joyca : C'est très bien
Squeezie : Aaah elle est bien !!
Joyca : Elle est bien, elle est bien
Squeezie : On prend un sandwich, on revient,
On check les pistes etc, on voit ce qu'on peut arranger
Et on bosse dessus jusqu'à la fin de l'aprem
[TOC TOC TOC]
Freddy : Je crois qu'on vient...
Kezah : Ah ! Eh bien rentrez !
Freddy : Vous venez pour nous... espionner ?
Squeezie (hors champ) : On va à la boulangerie acheter des sandwichs, vous en voulez ?
Freddy : Je crois que ça vaaaa...
Squeezie : Tu nous fais écouter un bout ?
Kezah : Naaan tranquille...
[Leur fait écouter une note]
Freddy : Oooooh !
[Rires de Freddy]
Freddy : Nan tout le reste c'est vraiment encore plus fou mec, c'est...
[Kezah dévoile 2 notes]
Freddy : ARRÊTE P*TAIN, QU'EST-CE QUE TU FAIS ??
Mec t'en donnes trop là, mec t'en donnes trop !
Squeezie : C'est le bruit qu'il y a quand tu lances un jeu,
Et que t'appuies sur "Start"...
Joyca : Je me suis assis sur mes lunettes.
[Rires de Kezah et Freddy]
Squeezie : Vous voulez des sandwichs ou pas ?
Kezah : Je suis plus sur un poulet-mayo moi
Freddy : Moi je suis plus sur de la MEFIANCE...
Kezah : Oooooh !
Squeezie : Bon les gars ! On revient pour te filer ton sandwich
Squeezie : C'est pas possible...
Là il est en train de faire le mix de la prod, il la "masterise"
D'ailleurs une photo de Natsu en train de masteriser la prod maintenant !
ça c'est un ptit challenge pour le monteur...
[bruits de pet + applaudissements]
Kezah : Théoriquement quand t'es sur une lancée et que tu tiens une bon truc
Kezah : tu t'arrête pas pour aller prendre un sandwich
Freddy : Est-ce que finalement ils vont chercher à manger ou chercher genre de l'inspi ?
Rire d'approbation de Kezah
Freddy : Très important quand on a pas de badge..
Kezah : Allez frotte moi comme dans le métro
Freddy : Voilà nickel
Freddy : Tout comme le badge quand on pas accès à l'ascenseur on se colle comme ça... Ah ben non ça marche pas pour l'ascenseur
Kezah : Bah non c'est pas, c'est pas utile
Kezah : Tu connais ce moment où on va arriver devant et on va tout entendre
Freddy : Aaaaah
Freddy : Il faudrait peut-être les prévenir ? Non
Kezah : Non
Kezah : Ça c'était le mur ça du coup
Kezah toque à la porte
Squezzie : Oui
Kezah : Salut
Squeezie : Cette tête qui dépasse c'est incroyable
Kezah : Je vous apporte une poubelle
Sqeezie : Ah cool, nice
Kezah : Comme ça vous pouvez jeter votre prod
Rires de Squeezie et Joyca
Joyca : Parce que vous vous pensez que vous allez faire un carton ?
Squeezie et Kezah : OOHHH
Kezah : Et t'es chaud toi dis donc
Freddy : T'as dis "jeter votre prod" mais si vous en avez trois les gars,  y'a de la place
Freddy : vous en avez fait 3 ?
Squeezie : Ouais
Squeezie : Il a compris à quel point elle était réussi sa blague
Squeezizi : Est-ce que vous voulez un mini indice ?
Kezah : un instrument
Joyca fait écouter une note